so I promised you that I would show you
some different ways for how to write the
second derivative and also explain what
this is about and I wonder if your brain
has been taking over as I've been
working on this and you can see why we
write it this way okay well I start with
some simpler ways okay we say the first
derivative another way to write it would
be Y - right
that's that's a way that you've seen it
okay alternatively you know like F dash
X they all mean the same thing okay so
therefore when you come to the second
derivative number one since a -
indicates differentiate right you
sometimes see this as y double dash this
is very common I still don't like it
because it looks like you know to the
power 11 but you know whenever you see
the notation okay well like yeah why is
your real name anyway
why don't ask okay that's one where C or
F Double Dash means exactly the same
thing now where did this come from and
how does it relate to this okay well
let's think about how the first one came
about DUI on DX okay another way of
saying it is okay I've got a function
sorry I just wanna not confuse this with
the graph I've got a function and it's
called wide but we said to differentiate
that is to stick a D on the X out the
front right drdx means differentiate
okay just like si a means to take the
sine of this value okay but you can see
all we've done just for convenience is
we'll check the wire at the top so do
you want e^x it's how Y is changing its
X is changing all right now if we do it
again
sorry axis if I take DUI DX okay the
whole thing and I differentiate that
okay which is how we got this success
right I would say D on DX of that okay
do you see what's happening
it actually is a bit weird still as a
way of notation but the D's on the top
there are two of them right D and then
another dip so that's why this d square
because you're doing a twice
where is on the bottom you've got the DX
and then you've got another DX so I
supposed to be really technical which
would probably say that right because
it's really all of DX you've got two of
them right hence DX square okay now
people are lazy and they are
I've always never seen that so this is
what they mean by a second derivative it
comes from here okay now just as before
I prefer this as your way of writing the
second derivative just like that refer
this is your own way of writing the
first year because it carries meaning
with it right
this means rise over run this means take
the first derivative and differentiate
again and also later on when you're not
differentiating with respect to X when
you're differentiating with respect to
other variables with these ones here you
can't tell what you're differentiating
with respect to it could be X or
the--not or power or H or whatever okay
whereas this actually tells you so it's
meaningful right I know it takes like a
whole one and a half seconds to write
the extra characters but I think they're
one hustings that are worth it wait wait
oh wait you mean like this you can I
mean I think it's equivalent to this i I
mean the people people write is to
distinguish it to distinguish it from
when you square a function okay but to
be honest when you've got better ways to
write it down that's gonna take some
smaller say just be a hundred and
hundred it's not so bad so that's what
the second derivative is okay